how are you Kurt I'm doing good buddy
how are you oh man I'm so excited for
you can't tie I'm excited I am for you I
really cannot tell you well I appreciate
it my friend we're we're excited too
trying to get all the last-minute
details done so we can get down there
and celebrate and I can celebrate all
those people that helped me be standing
on that stage so you got a written out
what do you got well I knew I got it
ready to go
I can't wait that's the thing I'm
looking forward to more than anything
else anything else is to get up on that
stage and hopefully be able to encourage
some people through through my story so
I do I got it ready to go just trying to
clean it up and so I'm so I'm ready to
go I haven't haven't worked with
teleprompters and some of that stuff
like you have cell phones
I'll try to memorize it as much as I can
so I can I can just put it out there so
how long have you been working on it and
what and you know I'll ask you multiple
questions about it so you can just go
through it how long you've been working
on it did you did you sit at a computer
did you hand write it what do you got
yeah not as long as some I talked to LT
about a month after we found out and his
was already done
Damien's was already done yeah he was I
can believe it he was done early and
then TD was done a little bit later so
I've been kind of keeping posted keeping
that posted with them on where they were
at mine came a lot later but but I have
worked on quite a bit in the last month
you know and when I got into it it was
really just you know I had a direction
that I wanted to go and I wanted to make
sure that you know obviously the right
people get thanked but that you do it in
a creative way and then more importantly
than anything else that that there's a
message behind it that hopefully people
can grab ahold of and take with them and
encourage them wherever they find
themselves and they put you in the last
spot to current stage in ups I don't
know what that means it means
everybody's going to be leaving all I
get there or or what but um you know
it's cool you see the last chance the
last words on that stage from the class
of 2017 to kind of to leave the event so
so I'm excited about it like I said I
I'm really I feel really good about
we're on that with this speech and I
you know if I can do it do it justice
that it be it'll be powerful well I mean
in your story Kurt Warner of the journey
everyone's so familiar with it but I'm
wondering what what was the moment where
you thought this may not happen and by
that means your football dream where was
the the darkest moment if you don't mind
recounting before the dawn I do mind but
you're going to hear about it
next Saturday night so I'm gonna I'm
gonna keep that under wraps a little bit
but you know you'll hear about different
moments that as you said you know it was
it's been a crazy ride and there's been
a lot of moments where you teetered on
okay is it time is it time to let it go
and move on and you know a lot of people
you find themselves you chasing your
dream and you find yourself right there
going okay what do I do at this moment
because what I do here probably dictates
everything else and you don't really
know what the right answer is because
you don't want to chase something that
you're never going to reach and you
spend half your life or you take
yourself or your family down a path that
that you don't want to go and then
there's the other side of it is that you
don't ever want to be the guy that's
sitting on your couch 25 years later
going man if I would have just got a
chance I could have been this and so so
there was a you know there was a few of
those moments in my career where I was
right there
you know and there were some some key
people that helped me to go just keep
going try one more time or were with you
or they encouraged you down that path
you know the people that you want to you
know on that stage to go thank you
understand you know your moment and what
that did for me because if it wasn't for
that I'm probably not here so since you
will avoid the specifics to keep your
speech as fresh as possible
Curt what would be when at that moment
where you thought it was darkest before
the dawn and if you in 2017 Kurt Warner
could go back and tell that that guy
something what would you tell that guy
Kurt um
you know I think I would just tell them
more than anything just to follow your
heart because I think too often in life
we let circumstances and we let people
dictate what we're going to do as
opposed to just chasing what we really
believe we should do and I think at the
end of the day that's that's what really
matters is that you know if you think
what you're doing is affecting people in
a negative way and you think it's
affecting your life in a negative way
you have to follow your heart even if
your head says man I really want to
accomplish that and then vice versa that
when people are saying give up you can't
do this it's not going to happen I mean
the writing's on the wall but if that's
what your passion is I think you have to
keep chasing it and that's what I think
I would say and I was fortunate that I
had some people that were willing to let
me chase that and Wehling willing to to
go after my passions even when it didn't
seem like the best thing not just for
maybe me at the time but for those
people that were involved in my life but
I think that's key is follow your heart
follow your passion because at the end
of the day that's what makes us happy
you know not even necessarily
accomplishing our dream it's chasing
your passion it's living in your passion
and what you were born to do and I think
that's what I would tell uh you know my
younger self when I was in some of those
moments Kurt Warner here in the Rich
Eisen show how many people are part of
the group this weekend how many people
are coming oh no well I mean obviously
you know the whole family beyond that
it's you know kind of touch-and-go
you know I think that and I couldn't
tell if you guys were kind of talking
about it the San Diego situation with I
saw your tweet today about that yeah you
know and again I if those are the facts
it disappoints me because I've also got
a number of guys coaches and players
that I want there and that deserve to be
there and a part of this that aren't
able to come either because because
they're in the midst of camps and doing
stuff and I guess I just don't I don't
understand it I just it's such a special
moment and all of us that are up on the
stage understand there were so many
people that went into this and so many
people
really when you go into the Hall of
things that go in with you and they
deserve the opportunity to enjoy that
moment as well because they earned it
and so that to me is the disappointing
part is some people some key people that
I want there are not able to be there
because of their football commitments
and I guess I just don't understand how
in the big picture when you're looking
at this whole thing how you don't
understand that and how important it is
you know LaDainian Tomlinson in the face
of the San Diego Chargers for so long
how do you not understand I need my guys
there you know whatever we have to do
flying in on a private jets are there a
half an hour before you know let them be
there with me and enjoy this moment and
then fly them back but you know I just I
think it's just disappointing because we
all understand we didn't get here by
ourselves you know there's key people
that were along for the journey that
deserved to appreciate their moment here
as well you know so disappointing it if
that's the facts and that's true
disappointing that the Danian couldn't
have some of his guys there and maybe
more importantly those guys that really
want to be there can't have the
opportunity to continue to support and
celebrate their teammate I mean well
said Kurt very well said there so who
who is coming most are most of the
greatest show on turf er is going to be
there Vermont yeah well you know we'll
have a number of them no question a
number of guys will be there obviously
you know a couple guys that are up on
that stage with me some of the other
receivers there there's going to be a
contingent from the Cardinals so my man
Fitz will be there along with a couple
of other players you know still waiting
to hear on a few other guys that are in
the midst of football stuff trying to
figure it out of coach of course coach
Vermeil and a number of my coaches will
be there as well so it will definitely
be well represented but I'm going to
miss those guys that that are
unfortunately not able to come couple
more minutes with you Kurt pound the
table for Isaac Bruce and Torry Holt our
poll question today involves number of
people who haven't been in the home what
do you think about these guys I mean
they're just you know as special as
anybody I've been around and you know
there's some great receivers there
there's some great guys that are going
to be on the docket I mean Randy Moss
you know Terrell Owens who's already
there Isaac's been up there Tory already
been there in that finalist group but
they're just they're special individuals
they played the game right and they
played it at a level that frankly we've
never seen before or that we've only
seen from a few and so you know I know
there's a ball game and how that kind of
works but those guys both deserve to be
in the Hall of Fame and I look forward
to the moment when they walk across that
stage but I think one thing that always
works against those guys is they played
together and we played at a time and had
the greatest show on turf when we had
lots of different guys you had another
Hall of Famer in the backfield and so
these are guys that whose numbers could
be even better than they already are and
they've already done things that very
few have ever done but they were very
unselfish Superstars that were great in
their own right but maybe didn't have
the blowout numbers that they could have
and I think that's part of the reason
why you know when you put in room and
you talk about all these guys those guys
sometimes cross each other out instead
of being able to set them aside and say
okay let's just look at how great this
guy was because if we do that and we
watched how he played and what he did
and what he meant to his team to me
they're both locks to be in the Hall of
Fame and I believe it will happen just a
matter of when have you been in a bus
crew member have you walked in that room
yeah I did you know one time a long time
ago actually when Marshall was inducted
the only time I've ever been to the Hall
of Fame I took my my middle son and we
got a chance to take a little tour the
Hall of Fame's the only time I've ever
been there and got to go in the bus room
and check it out but that's the only
time and the rest of my family has never
been there so I look forward to now
you're through with them now you're
going you're in it you're going to be in
I can't believe it this is so awesome
you deserve this you deserve this so
long ago you know I don't know I don't
know you know let me blow not to say
anything you just seriously Curt you
deserve this so long ago and it is so
well deserved and it's just it and just
knowing you and your wife and what you
do in the community in Arizona and it's
just the beginning - it's so awesome and
I'm so thrilled and honored that I will
be the emcee of the jacket
and all of us at the end at the NFL
Network will be there with you for you
by you and it's awesome well thank you
you are my life dealer but I don't know
if I sit or not but I'm not giving it
back I'm going to take it and we're
going to we're going to enjoy it and
like I said I'm going to hopefully use
it because that to me is what this whole
thing has been about is using it to to
thank the right people to celebrate with
the right people and hopefully encourage
a lot of people along the way that hey
if I can do it you know there's no by no
means if I cornered any market so
there's a lot of other people out there
can do it as well if if they keep
chasing the opportunity and I can't wait
to see that bust resting on that
plexiglass curve where it says Kurt
Warner and the teams are Cardinals
Giants Rams Admirals and Barnstormers
right they're all going to be there
they're all going to be there I mean
right I'm not there without it
and so without all those teams I hope so
with a laptop right it's the flat top
look - right you'll see you'll see
you're not given anything with a sack
come on come on the hardest part when
they actually ask you to do the bust and
you know they're like what do you want
and you know you got this whole you know
time period of you know from haircuts to
facial hairs and as to that okay I'm
like I don't know I mean I don't want it
to be about me I want it to be what
other people see so yeah so it was it
was an interesting process and I tell
you what my wife was as much involved
you know if I ever said I don't even
know if it looks like it looks like Tom
Hardy or somebody as long as you think
it looks good when she walks in that
country that's all good oh man I'd say
if it ever happened something with me I
would definitely turn to Suzie Inglewood
what do you think Kurt man I love you
can't wait to see in Ohio and be part of
this thing with awesome buddy I can't
wait to see you as well you going to
that's Kurt one the Rich Eisen shows
weekdays at noon eastern on radio
stations across the country and audience
if you like that please download our app
there's lots of fun things there other
than just more of the videos you just
saw you can call us from the app you can
email us from the app just download it
trust me you'll enjoy